en una noche húmeda y lúgubre en sao
paulo las noticias no fueron mejores el
martes el gobierno anunció que había
identificado dos casos de la variante
omicron del hobbit 19 en el estado
brasileño en una nación que ya ha
perdido a seiscientas mil personas a
causa del virus la posibilidad de otra
ola tiene a muchos asustados
aunque estoy vacunada no sé si me
servirá si me contagio con la nueva
variante muda una preocupación que se
extiende por todo el mundo en corea del
sur los contagios superaron los 5.000 la
primera vez que esto ocurre en el país
desde que comenzó la pandemia y muchos
temen que la variante omicron que se
cree altamente contagiosa puede empeorar
las cosas especialmente si los
científicos descubren que las vacunas no
la neutralizan según me gustaría que
bloquearán todos los vuelos procedentes
de países con casos confirmados de
omicron para que los contagiados no
pudieran entrar en el aeropuerto
las restricciones de viaje han vuelto a
aparecer japón anunció que suspendía a
las nuevas reservas de bolos además de
bloquear la llegada de viajeros
extranjeros al igual que japón más de
una docena de países han prohibido los
viajes desde varias naciones del sur de
áfrica donde se está extendiendo la
nueva variante eeuu no dicho cuánto
durará la restricción pero la casa
blanca ha confirmado que está estudiando
la posibilidad de endurecer los
requisitos de las pruebas en algunos
lugares como países bajos bélgica y
alemania los investigadores han
descubierto que la nueva variante lleva
en sus países más tiempo del que se
pensaba la cuestión es que en el momento
en que surge una nueva variante y se
anuncia probablemente la propagación o
la variante ya está extendida por todo
el mundo es decir por la forma en que se
propagan estas variantes del colon a
virus no hay forma de evitar que se
propague a nivel mundial la o&m se ha
advertido que las prohibiciones de
viaje- no detendrán la propagación del
virus llegando a ser incluso
perjudiciales ya que podrían disuadir a
los países de compartir información
crítica sobre su situación
lógica